can i have your attention please
[Music]
it's now my pleasure to introduce the
star of dance party
let's give them a big hand
the golden voice from the golden state
casey kasem
for our dance contest this week now is
everybody ready
you know through the years i've been to
a lot of schools i've met a lot of
principals but i have never met a
principal
who was so caring so involved and so hip
as your own big bumper building
thank you thank you case man now can i
have the banner
of course one minute everybody
stand by and enjoy yourselves i could
twist and sing
let go of the microphone
and now so thank you so much for the
announcement of our three finalists who
will all dance for you one more time
and then we'll pick the winner with your
applause are you ready with the applause
meter max
ready casey our first finalists the
exciting
spandex twins kelly kapowski and ac
[Applause]
slater
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
very good now for finalist number two
the powerhouse preppies welcome zack
morris and jesse spano
[Music]
all right now for our final couple with
a new dance they've invented called
the sprain screech powers and lisa
turtle
bring them on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there is no doubt about it we have a
winner it is screech and lisa
all right well that's a good night from
us here at
dance party everybody till next time
this is casey case i'm saying keep your
feet in the ground
and keep reaching for the stars come on
everybody
let's do the the sprain
you